l'activité de forgeron est apparue en
même temps que la découverte du travail
des métaux environ 5000 ans avant
Jésus-Christ elle est devenue un métier
à part entière à mesure que les peuples
exprimè leur besoin d'avoir des objets
plus résistants et aux usages variés les
premiers forgerons ont commencé exercer
sur l'île de la Réunion à l'époque de la
colonisation leur tâche principale
fabriquer des outils des armes des
parties mécaniques ou encore des
bijoux aujourd'hui la technique et les
outils se sont modernisés avec les
machines le travail est rendu moins
pénible et plus rapide pourtant quelques
irréductibles ont choisi de rester dans
la
tradition er est forgeron sa spécialité
c'est la taillanderie il travaille
toujours à l'ancienne benah mais c'est
le seul Taillandier le vrai he
Taillandier de lîle c'est un métier
ancestral travaille toujours à
l'ancienne c'est dire au charbon de bois
a bien côté patrimoine aussi côté rester
ancien VO parce que Mo a été enseigné
dansancienneté novadia fabriquer des
outils anciens tout ça donc il est
toujours en moi donc les G pas fait
autrement et travailler à l'ancienne
c'est aussi faire preuve d'imagination
et utiliser ce qu'on a sous la main eric
a fabriqué lui-même ses machines et
plusieurs de ses outils et une grosse
partie des matières premières qu'il
utilise viennent de la récupération si
acheter des machines tout
neuf par exemple la machine qui moi là
on a pour 15 à 20000 €
alors 400 € tout ce qui sort d'une
voiture d'un camion ou de d'un d'un
transport moi j'utilise pour transformer
C cet asset là là un outil la plupart
des des outils que je fabrique c'est à
travers ces méteaux recyclés et de voir
ce que l'on peut obtenir en transformant
du métal récupéré et tout simplement
stupéfiant Samuel est forgeron coutelier
une autre spécialité de la forge il
fabrique des couteaux à partir de
matériaux de récupération parfois
étonnant à
l'époque les gens avaient pas des des
bars directement de si RUAG fait au
moyen âge ou are c'est il trouvaent des
cailloux ferreux ou des trucs comme ça
et il faisait le propre Assier on essaie
de récupérer soit des des chaînes de
vélo des chaînes tronçonneuses des
vieilles limes du fer à béton
aussi des lames de ressort de camion des
tirons de
coffrage un peu de tout commercial de
formation Samuel a touché un peu à tout
du bâtiment à l'informatique en passant
par les assurances avant de faire de sa
passion son métier un métier ancestral
qui a encore de l'avenir donc j'ai envie
je roule pas sur l' mais je me fais
vivre je fais vivre ma famille donc
c'est
l'essentiel ça parce que c'est une
passion toute façon après moi on a
toujours quelqu'un d'autre qui va
continuer le
métier